if you're on hold to a company and
they're playing music down the phone at
Anu the chances are it sounds terrible
and sometimes it just dissolves into
static telephone signals are not
designed to carry music and to explain
why we have to start way way back with
old telephone equipment like this early
telephone calls were put through by a
human operator who would be literally
connecting the two phone wires into one
circuit at a big board of switches or a
switchboard any sound at one end whether
its speech music or whatever would be
converted to an electrical signal sent
down the wire and converted back at the
other end you send music you receive
music all those would be limited by the
abilities of the tiny microphone and
speaker but telephone exchanges like
this only work for small numbers of
connections because you know you can't
do this for every call phone companies
quickly realized that they could save on
setting up thousands of wires between
exchanges miles apart if they were able
to put several conversations down one
wire at the same time
so rather than transmit every frequency
of sound in the original signal they
would cut off the high and low
frequencies the one that we don't
absolutely need to understand speech and
then they would shift each call into a
different frequency band and at the
other end like tuning in a radio they
would shift each call back to the right
frequencies so you could hear it I mean
the quality wasn't great but it was good
enough and hey we got cheap
long-distance calling we got used to
that phone quality sound and it became
the standard so already music was gonna
sound a bit dodgy with all the high and
low frequencies cut off but while we're
still running on analog circuits it
wasn't gonna sound like static that was
the fault of computers phone companies
realized they could cram even more calls
down the same wire or into the same
airspace on a cellular network if they
use computers to compress the audio and
the more they compressed it the more
calls they could fit at the same time
and the cheaper to default these days
there is enough power in pretty much
everyone's phone to compress 4k video in
real time but back then not so much mp3
had only just been invented and these do
not have enough power to compress those
the standards for phone calls even today
rely on quick-and-dirty compression
built decades ago designed to run on
very little computing power and
optimized for speech that compression is
great as I'm coding one clear voice but
check a load of complicated music at it
with all instruments but not quite
enough to break down into static there
is one last piece of the puzzle someone
else cutting corners because in the
worst case that hold music isn't just
compressed by the phone company on its
way to you it's already been compressed
by a completely different system as you
call bounces around a company's internal
phone network an internal phone network
that has probably been built by the
lowest bidder
so the phone company takes that already
mangled signal and mangles it in a
different way as it travels to you and
in a really badly designed system maybe
there's an entire third layer of
terrible compression from whichever
other company runs the call center that
you're actually talking to off in some
other country speech can survive that
chain but music these music palms thank
you so much to all the team at the
Milton Keynes Museum and they're
connected earth gallery where pretty
much all this telephone exchange
equipment is just open to play around
with pull down the description for more
about them this is not a TARDIS this is
literally just a police telephone box